[Music]  it's very heavy and everything is very  strategically placed there's not much  moving around  it was the second dress I tried on and I  just I feel like I'm gonna do that all  night because I bought one to wear a  cape I feel like a quasi superhero in it  oh she's down there over there yeah yeah  they're gonna shine now look stunning  those who took longer to get ready  tonight come on  early so that it was a pleasant  experience and not rushed and since I  don't have any children with me here  which is different I bump in time  I took almost three hours which is  excruciating for me to sit still I'm  very excited to wear it and I I almost  slept in it it's that comfortable  it is Christian Siriano he made a custom  for me in them I'm so honored and you  know and because it's so tight but it  has to be for the effect the column  effect I'm going for its Ralph Lauren  Couture it's beautiful and my jewelry is  Lorraine Schwartz